put it in
[Applause]
i'm tired of people thinking i'm some
kind of joke your dad and i agreed it
would be best if you just stop being who
you are and doing the things you love
my whole life
all i wanted i'm afraid we found your
son at a polka party
is to make up new words to a song that
already exists
oh
well you should do that then
my little hungry one hungry one open up
a package
[Music]
dude i've got chills
every once in a great while
i can spot a talent
that i know is the future of music
but first we gotta find you a stage name
al yankovic it's long it's hard to
pronounce so i'm just gonna throw this
out there weird al yankovic
i love it
do i know you madonna i was wondering if
you were going to do a parody of my song
like a virgin i'm curious is that song
autobiographical yes
except for the fact that i've had a lot
of sex
[Music]
maybe one creative genius that doesn't
have a checkered past involving alcohol
and medicine
drugs
i think madonna's a bad influence on you
what no offense
i'm a train wreck
my parents wrote me off
i pushed away my band you're all just a
bunch of normal i'm the weird one you
gotta take care of yourself i saw on you
something special an artist
with something to give to the world
in front of all the billions of people
watching around the world right now
all i want to say is be as weird as you
want to be
you will never find true happiness
so you can truly accept who you are
[Music]
thank you
oh
you can't smoke in here
i totally deserve that
you